hey guys welcome back to our channel my
name is samuel and i'm amanda and this
is the samuel and amanda show where we
talk about money marriage and life and
in this video we're gonna actually be
focusing in on marriage and you know
what it's so amazing how many people are
getting married at the moment i mean we
had some proposals just in the last week
oh my gosh yes
and we feel like it would be a good idea
as we've just celebrated last month our
six-year wedding anniversary and as a
lot of our friends and colleagues and
students are
proposing to one another and getting
married we found ourselves quite
recently given quite a lot of marriage
advice um and
what qualifies someone to give married
advice
well someone who's married for starters
yeah someone's got good marriage yeah uh
someone's been mad for a long time six
years is is it's all relative so we're
gonna do our best um we're not perfect
human beings but i must say we do have a
pretty good marriage yeah we do and we
only speak from our experience as well
and we can only speak from our
experience so
in fact well when i say we can speak my
experience literally
individually as well like i've got seven
things that i've written which i'm
hiding from amanda seven things that
i've written that i think
is the best marriage advice i could give
some of these things we have spoken
about um just in the past some we
haven't so i'm gonna read them out one
by one and amanda i want you to tell me
if you agree okay because some of these
things we've not spoken about okay i was
talking to evans recently by the way if
you enjoy the channel hit like subscribe
and all that jazz but i was thinking to
evans recently and evans
got um engaged to ellen a few days ago
and before he proposed to ellen i had a
serious conversation with evans and i
basically said to him because evans
anyone that doesn't know evans
last year he had nothing he was sharing
a single bed with his girlfriend living
in his girlfriend's parents house no
money now evans is doing really well
he's buying a hotel he's on his way to
becoming a property millionaire he's
making about 10 to 15 000 pounds clean
profit a month and i said to evans
really important lesson this is my
advice to him i said the women
don't care that much
about money
now i'm kind of just speaking from my
experience but you think i'm going to
give you my justification and say why is
that it and then you tell what you think
okay
i've seen a lot of people a lot of guys
that start making lots of money and they
become almost they change when they
start making their money or they don't
change but they just
they feel like if they're bringing home
the bacon
that's all they need to do if they're
bringing home the bacon well
they've done their job and then as a
result you can neglect your wives
emotional needs you can um forget that
actually because i don't feel like
amanda's that bothered if we were living
in a small house
and you're you're able to eat and stuff
as a guy it's easy to think oh man we
just did a million pounds a deal but
actually i don't think it matters that
much to women it's more important that
you're just there and present and able
to provide but whether you're making a
hundred grand a year or a million pounds
a year or 10 million pounds a year kind
of doesn't really matter that much to
your wife probably as much as you think
so
what do you think about that
i actually agree yeah i do i don't think
like you said if we lived in a i don't
know a smaller house or whatever none of
that matters to me i think what matters
is having the love from you yeah so i
think it's great if you're really
successful and you're making lots of
money but i think when you truly love
someone those material things aren't the
basis of your marriage and your
relationship it's you know it's just
like a bonus to have but really what
really matters is having someone that
loves you unconditionally yeah and ellen
evans partner
i'm like she was crazy about evans when
he had 23 pounds in the bank
she was riding with him and supporting
him
and i think you need to remember where
you came from a little bit when you
start making lots of money so my advice
this is a finance channel as well we're
talking here about marriage but is if
you're becoming very successful which a
lot of people are there's literally
there's millions of millionaires
across the world and i think i can't
know what the exact stat was i think
there was five million people that
became a millionaire throughout 2020 and
i'm seeing so many people become
successful financially making lots of
money become financially free but as far
as your marriage is concerned don't
forget to not neglect your marriage and
women don't care that much about you
being a millionaire a multi-millionaire
as long as you can put food on the table
so that's the first thing okay second
thing that i've got here is this
um and that is to learn each other's
love language
so talk to me about that so true i think
that it's important to know each other's
love language so what are the love
languages there's um acts of service
there's quality time
there's touch let's touch one of them
there's gifts and there's words of
affirmation so i think sometimes if you
are in a relationship you need to know
how they want to receive love because
say for example
i
loved words of affirmation samuel but
you never gave me words of affirmation
then i wouldn't feel loved i'm like okay
i might keep getting amanda gifts all
the time yeah hey i got you a gift i got
you a gift and she's like
i don't want that yeah i want with your
words of affirmation i.e hey i really
appreciate you i love you so much thanks
for being there for me today yeah that
might be what so you so true everybody
everybody who's got different um ways
that they like to receive love and don't
assume that your partner's love language
is the same as yours yeah because you
might like being touched you might like
being touched that might be the way you
feel loved but your partner might not so
you when you're trying to love your
partner you might touch them because you
think that that's what they would like
because that's what you like but
actually they've got a whole different
love language
so go figure out what it is yeah and how
do you know what their love language is
ask them
communication not rocking science so not
matter what is your love language how do
you most like and what's your best and
worst
what's your you think the thing that
resonates with you most at least oh
okay the most i would say words of
affirmation
that's easy
and my least oh
i'd probably say
the least is gifts gift is the least the
crazy thing is i think i'm probably the
same we have a very similar love
language but you don't have to have a
similar love language to your partner
you just have to know you just have to
know what it is yeah all right next the
seven by the way so i hope you enjoyed
this if you want to hit the like button
next is
to protect each other's peace
what i mean by that is
i run a very stressful life okay we've
got a lot of properties a lot of tenants
a lot of uh training events a lot of
staff a lot of customers a lot of all
kinds of stuff crazy going on juggling
at once and amanda
was when we got married you know really
was quite a rock in the business and she
still is today but amanda was in charge
at one point of managing all of our hmo
managers they might not sound very
difficult managing managers
but mandy said to me managing property
managers can be just as demanding as
managing tenants and i think for me it's
really important as a man but also you
know
as a woman as well i think because a
manly protects my piece as well when i
saw that amanda was kind of like getting
really stressed out with the
with the with the uh managing the
managers and stuff
especially when we when we had ruby
my thinking is as a man i don't want to
just protect amanda physically from harm
or emotion i want to protect her in
every which way including her peace and
again a lot of
businessmen
and i'm probably guilty
can put on their wives okay so could be
like oh can you do this can you do this
can you do this can you just do this and
i'm i'm quite probably quite demanding
to live with i'm probably quite
demanding just as a person generally
but i think it's important to just check
in and make sure that their peace is
okay and that they're
um you know that for me making sure that
amanda is cool she's happy and if she's
not like i'm the first oh rip things
from her yeah you do samuel's very much
like if you at all senses that i'm
unhappy about something
you know stressing and stressing out
then you're just like totally just like
okay you're not doing it yeah i'll rip
it from here yeah because my job is to
protect amanda's piece and if she feels
stressed or
whatever it is whether it's with the
kids it's like right we're getting a
nanny if it's with the hmo managing the
hmo managers right we're getting a new
overseer straight away
um but you protect my piece as well in
other ways but that's what i think what
do you have to say yeah no i totally
agree with that i think it's really
important and lots of people always say
to me at events like oh thank you so
much for like releasing your husband to
let him do this because i feel like some
wives when their husbands are like you
are maybe you're just at home nagging
nagging nagging that i feel like is just
unnecessary and not needed so i think i
do a lot to support you yeah and the
last thing that i want to do is like put
on you or stress you out like you do so
much and i think that when you come home
i just want samuel to just relax and
just not have to
you know oh i appreciate it i appreciate
that
um i really appreciate that so okay
potentially this piece next is it is
better to be kind than to be right
again you can try and win the argument
it doesn't matter
just
be kind to your partners at all times
and
you know we don't really argue much
thankfully we're pretty compatible but
guys out there and girls out there never
try and win the argument because it
doesn't matter which actually takes me
to my next point which is you're on the
same team so true no you're on the same
team yeah pulling in the same direction
what you have to say yeah and when
you're together you go further then if
you're like pulling one direction and
your partner's pulling in the other
direction yeah you know so
you're a team and you should you know be
what's the word i'm looking for
together united united united
totally united this is the point number
six is never ever undermine your partner
never undermine them um especially in
public so if amanda's telling the story
and i'm like
i don't think it quite but you see those
couples where it's like
what someone someone's telling a story
they was like no no no no it was
actually wednesday night and it's like
whoa
it's so like it's annoying yeah it is i
hate to watch that it's not necessary
amanda's telling the story and she says
oh and then we you know then we did this
that and the other and she gets the date
wrong or the time wrong or whatever
wrong
i'm not gonna step in and go no actually
you got that wrong like
because it's just annoying
and undermining one another oh man it's
so disgusting to see when a married
couple
you know one of them will like roll
their eyes at the other person oh she
always does that or if i see like
a guy who's married who's wife and he'll
like make some joke at her expense yeah
so not cool again it all roots back to
being on the same team you know
you have to be rooting for each other
supporting each other because if you're
not then who else who else will what do
you think those were because i think as
well there's something within the the
spirit of when something's said so will
sometimes diss each other as a joke like
she'll be like oh whatever big head or
you know we'll just
jokingly yeah like to take the mickey
out of each other
what's the difference between that
and actually undermining one another
oh i'd probably say the difference
between that and undermining is probably
just
that sometimes say if there's like
something that you know your partner is
sensitive about so when we're like when
i'm saying like oh hey big head or
whatever
quite sensitive
i know you're not sensitive about your
video so it's just like oh it's just a
bit banter but i think if i took
something that i know
is something that you see my big ears
for instance
then you know then i feel like then
you're saying it in a mean spirit and
then it's you know it's not funny and
then again it's making your partner feel
embarrassed and then you know it's just
it's just i think i think it's the
spirit like we banter a lot we'll joke
sometimes ask a man to submit even in
public if we're amongst friends or
whatever she might say you know
oh who do you think you are there what
but she's totally joking and i can joke
back and um
you know as soon as i say go get me a
drink let's not stab my fingers but i'm
completely kidding yeah
and she'll just go like i'm completely
kidding that's not what i'm talking
about it's more like manzie could
literally
cuss me out and be taking the mickey out
of me and i wouldn't mind if i know that
the spirit is she's just joking but if
she just raised her eyebrows
and i sensed that she was unhappy i'd be
like
whoa
like literally or if i sense the crap
you know the cracking the cracking
i can tell when manny's upset when i'm
about to cry when i get upset before i
even
just when i speak samuel was like she's
okay
just cracks a tiny bit and it's so funny
because sometimes
i wouldn't even guess that she'd be
upset about it so we're just having a
normal conversation
um
and then she'll be talking and then
she'll the the crap oh damn she's upset
i don't know yeah and i'm like whoa or
or
if us if
i think it's about the spirit it's about
wanting to you wanting to love the
person not undermine them boost them up
but yeah at the same time if you're
kidding around then i guess it's
different as long as they're okay even
if i was kidding around if i was taking
the mickey out of amanda jokingly and
she was if i sensed that even one 0.1
percent of i was upset about it i would
immediately stop um all right last one
is
love one another but also love yourself
and be independent and
i'll tell you what i think about that
you know what you think as well you know
people call themselves when they say oh
my other half
i don't like that because this idea that
you're not one without them i feel like
you want to come to your partner as a
whole
being
independent and and and and
otherwise you can be a bit needy or a
bit clingy or i need them like we live
very independent lives as well as very
together as well so what do you think
about that yeah i agree i think that you
have to really love yourself and it's
like that thing when they say you can't
fill you can't pour from an empty cup
yeah so i can't give in to our
relationship if i'm not whole in myself
yeah so i think that it's really
important that
i'm not trying to be fulfilled by samuel
i fulfilled it myself and then together
it's you know it's even bigger and
better than the cup over overflow yeah
exactly if you're trying to be happy but
you're trying to be happy by somebody
else and you're like ah this person
needs to make me happy this person needs
to make me feel a certain way you're
putting way too much pressure on that
person and that's that that's what leads
to clingy nurse saying oh where are you
i miss you come back home i'll arsenal's
go away for days at a time and we'll
miss each other but mandy's not pining
at home well maybe a little bit
waiting by the window
no you're not like you're doing anything
so i think yeah i think come as a whole
person
find fulfillment not in each other i
mean as christians we find fulfillment
in god
we find fulfillment in it we're
independently happy but then we come
together as one yeah one plus one makes
one so we're one together but we're also
one apart i'm not half a person mandy's
not half a person without me
um so that's my final one do you have
anything else to add to that no i think
i agree with all of them and i think
that it's really important to put
put each other's feelings
first and to always consider how your
partner's feeling and even if you think
that they're wrong again does that
matter right yeah there's no right or
wrong they're just kind or not kind
and
i think as well
um water the garden you know we we and
i've said there's so many guys so many
young guys that started in business
we spend so much time on our businesses
trying to grow our businesses with our
customers with our staff
marriage isn't hard work i have not
found it hard work but
it's not hard work when you water the
garden when you water it you've got to
put time into your marriage um
go out on date nights value your
partners value your wives and also
marriage is a beautiful thing i love
marriage i love being married i love
committing to somebody and
i'm not i'm definitely not perfect okay
no way i'm nowhere near perfect um what
i am is i'm committed and i think
committing to somebody and giving
somebody your all is a beautiful thing
so guys if you're with your girls and
you've been together for a few years
and they're waiting for you to propose
but you're like oh what's the point of
being married stop being a [ __ ] get the
ring out and commit okay because
marriage is a beautiful thing so thanks
for watching my name's samuel and i'm
amanda and we'll see you next time see
you guys